Stafford's got it looks looks low blows
deep middle
[Applause]
there was a heck of a throw and Dan
Miller with a great call on the Lions
radio network as the Lions beat the
Chargers and now move on to take on the
Eagles in Philadelphia in week number
three and the quarterback in his 11th
season with the Detroit Lions Matthew
Stafford back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Matthew I am good all
right family first how's your wife how
is she doing
oh she's doing good I appreciate you
asking you know she's uh she's been a
warrior been battling through all that
stuff but she's she's feeling really
good and it's it's nice to have her
feeling pretty normal again my best I
bet and as she been to a game I mean how
back to to life is she right now yeah
she's yeah she's back to normal enough
to be a game she was at the first home
game this past weekend and it was great
to have her there it was nice obviously
winning the game and getting the sear
afterwards and she was happy and excited
so those people that don't know her
don't see her every day probably would
say she looks just about normal so I'm
happy for that and how much of
outpouring did you get I mean walk me
through what what you receive from the
fan base of the the great people of that
great state of Michigan and maybe
Georgia or wherever you've you've set
foot Matthew yeah it's been pretty
incredible um you know I know we got a
bunch of calls and letters into you know
the facility here in Detroit and they
were nice enough to pass those along to
me and then I think Kelly through her
social media stuff got just I don't even
know how much I'm not on it but a ton of
ton of support people who have been you
know great and and gracious to us about
that and and everywhere we go it's kind
of nice now everybody used to come out
to talk to me about the game on Sunday
now they just go up and talk to her and
I get if I get a free pass that's great
that's good I'm glad it's all it's all
it's all trending upward and it's all
good
and your family's great and you've got
your mind set on on football which
clearly worked out well for you this
week and your relationship that you're
having on the field with Kenny gala day
seems to improve and get stronger every
week how does that work from your
standpoint Matthew yeah it's been great
you know I think along with Kenny I mean
all our guys we just we put in so much
work during the weeks you know so much
time with each other so much hard work
out on the practice field and that's
just trust in that preparation and going
out there and and letting it fly on
Sunday their plays in that game I want
back no question but I thought we play
great situational football when we had
to have it late in the game
whereas probably week one we played
better early in the game and didn't
finish it so it was nice to nice to
finish the game off the right way on
offense and then obviously slay with the
huge pick on defense and we were able to
close it out so it's it's just through
hard work bunch of work together bunch
of time together and and just been going
out there and trusting that and your
fellow SEC backfield mate in carry on
Johnson I mean he had one maneuver or
series of maneuvers this week that was
remarkable I don't know how he does it
I'm wondering what's level of
improvement you've seen from him he's
been great you know I think you need did
a great job coming back from his
injuries at the end of the year last
year and you know he just kind of picked
up where he left off had a great play on
the screen pass earlier in the game
scored a touchdown there and then I know
it's when you're talking about twisting
and turn for us about 11 or 12 yard game
but it was some pretty impressive stuff
so he's got a ton of talent and you know
we'll continue to try and get him the
ball let him do his thing
eleventh season for Matthew Stafford
here on the Rich Eisen show and you know
so much discussion being made about how
difficult your division is and
interestingly enough you mentioned your
wife social media feed it played into
the conversation that you know a lot of
folks are having about this division is
to who will win it based on how well
they chug a beer Matthew and I'm
wondering how much stock you put in all
that because it seems that everybody has
been on some form of a video chugging a
beer in that division at
quarterback spot yeah I don't put much
stock into it and was a little bit more
of an offseason thing but now I did the
tough division it is got great defenses
great quarterbacks you know it's it's uh
it's a tough one to get wins and you
know there's there's a bunch of players
in this league that are that are
top-flight players in the league and a
bunch of organizations that are really
good as well so it's it's tough
okay so again back to the beer stuff
though how how much of a veteran are you
at this because again we're seeing we're
seeing I feel good about I feel good
about my game in that area but uh it
doesn't matter too much right now okay
no really just one beer at a time and
hope for the best that's what you just
did right there okay very good and and
it's interesting to Matthew you know
today obviously the news in the NFL is
Eli Manning has been sat down by the
Giants after all these years and I'm
wondering you're 31 years old do you
think at all about your end game
whatsoever of your car not really you
know I just I feel like I'm still you
know young enough to keep playing for
for quite a while you know the biggest
thing for me it's just health if you can
stay healthy and play at a high level
then I'd love to keep playing Eli's been
a fantastic quarterback in this league
for a long time guys got a couple Super
Bowls he's he's a great player um you
know that's a that's a tough decision
I'm sure for the organization I got a
lot of respect for what he's done and
how he's played you know for quite a
long time who was your mentor growing up
or at Giorgio's or even that you've had
in Detroit Matthew who was that guy for
you
yeah I've had a lot of people along the
way I had a quarterback coach it Georgia
Mike Bobo that was really influential on
on my you know growth as a quarterback
he's now the head coach at Colorado
State you know a bunch of people along
the way I've been lucky enough to have a
bunch of great backup quarterbacks and
veteran guys drew stand early in my
career Sean Hill as well Dan Orlovsky
some guys that you know are really
influential when I was young to really
help me you know know what it's like to
be a
quarterback and how to go about your
business and all that kind of stuff so I
was lucky and this week you know you and
I have something in common
Matthew not just a in just in any whole
week what we have in common is we're
both going to be rooting very hard
against Notre Dame because just that's
the way I'm wired as a Michigan
Wolverine and this week your Georgia
Bulldogs take take that squad on will
you watch that game in Philadelphia do
you do already have this already mapped
out a little bit for you this weekend
I will try and catch it no question
that's a big one I know we played there
either last year or two years ago I
can't remember I think I might have been
two years ago but it was uh it was a
great game I think Georgia kind of
bought a bunch of seats and came out
strong so it'll be interesting to see it
Notre Dame tries to repay the favor but
it'll be it'll be a great game I'm
excited I know it's a huge a huge deal
in Athens right now that you know
they're gonna be game day and all that
stuff so it should be a lot of fun yeah
do you speak to Jake from have you been
mentoring him in any way shape or form I
know I don't speak to him too much to be
honest with you on some old guy he's
probably barely ever heard of come on
but no I haven't spoken to him too much
of met him before been out there but I
don't keep in contact with some of those
guys okay and then with the Dodgers
getting set for pro season play at some
point when Kershaw is on the man will
invariably hear the well-known fact that
you went to high school together
so watch when did you first meet Clayton
Kershaw I've never asked you this I'd
love to get into that relationship do
you remember the first time you ever
strolled up to Clayton I mean I think we
had to have been probably on a soccer
field when we were five six years old
something like that really yeah we met I
think playing on the same old blue
bomber soccer team and ended up playing
a bunch of baseball together a bunch of
basketball together a bunch of football
together so I've known him for a really
long time I've really enjoyed watching
his career it's been really impressive I
got a really good team this year so I'm
excited he's a good dude man
I mean I'm the best if you really I'm
serious like and I'm not just saying cuz
I know you're tight and you're on the
phone right now yeah he live
in the area where I go trick-or-treating
with my kids every year and I was
dressed as mr. incredible with my kids
last year and strolled up and who was
the guy handing out candy but Clayton
Kershaw and yeah I don't know it's
pretty cool I don't know if I'd ever met
him before and and he was really cool
for a guy who was dressed as mr.
Incredibles saying hello to him you know
it was it was really odd yeah he's he's
super down-to-earth guy a great guy and
obviously and you know unbelievable
athlete and all that but a great family
man obviously does a bunch for charity
as well so I know he's uh he's doing a
great job in the community there he's a
good dude Hey before I let you go you
had a front row seat I imagine at some
point to see Kyler Murray or just peak
out on the field he's the first guy
since cam to throw for 300 yards in his
first two games I'm wondering what your
impression of that the first overall
selection like you you have something in
common there what your first impression
of him was I was you know I was really
impressed you know we got up in that
game he did a great job bringing his
team back made some great plays late in
the game
he's ultra talented I think he's got a
system that fits him really well he
obviously knows it's played a played a
bunch of ball on it in college so you
know he's got that advantage going for
him and and got a Hall of Fame receiver
that he can throw it to so I think you
know some good things are ahead for him
and that team yeah and and he like you
started from jump game 1 straight out of
the first overall selection with Daniel
Jones now getting out there obviously
it's week 3 and we know how sometimes
guys sit and wait did it did it help you
to be thrown right out there right away
Matthew I think so but I think
everybody's different you know and I
know that it's works both ways you know
guys is played for a long time been
really successful after waiting a few
years I know guys have been really
successful after you know starting day
one so it's kind of you know up to the
organization up to the team and the head
coach at that time and and I was happy
to keep playing because I really never
missed the season for a long time so I
was ready to to get out there and play
and I took my lumps no question and
learn from
Matthew thanks for the call I'm glad to
hear about your wife doing so well and I
was thinking of you and your family at
that time and just thrilled to see you
everything working out so well I really
appreciate that thanks for having me you
got it that's Matthew Stafford Lions
quarterback right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app